tchité prison ces pros ferait mieux de
rentrer
entendu le message de bande n'a plus de
copains ploquin moyenne communiqué
réponds quoi je suis vraiment voir ici
j'ai quand même réussi à vous amener
jusqu'ici non c'est pas bon qu'il avait
ni claire ni un autre témoin
on a réussi à passer
mais maintenant tu voudrais qu'on rentre
non
ça on est allé trop loin pour annoncer
maintenant
pour les abandonner
pas tant de commandes
gilbert
tout est là
vous n'êtes pas de sauver la vie tant la
chaloupe et en mille morceaux il en
reste rien alors arrête maintenant
une chaloupe partir en fumée aussi
déchaîné
cantate navire il aura coulé ici la
tombée de la nuit chacun d'entre vous
ici d'en sortir vivants mais pour ça y'a
qu'un moyen
il faut qu'on passe temps sans dalle et
échoué quelque part pour mettre en place
une ligier chargés de repérer les au
point j'aurai besoin de quatre hommes
pour manoeuvrer le gouvernail de fortune
si de quatre hommes responsables des
propos niveau du moteur tous les autres
vous allez former une chaîne qui
communiquent entre le pont supérieur et
la salle des machines
et s'il vous plaît quelqu'un en accion
s'étirait vous avez entendu les gars bon
boulot réclusion
alors c'est leur donner accès vaut
maintenant ta gang
j'espère que vous venez pas nous
condamner
fixe + moteur a calé
bah c'est bon je m'en occupe non
vous avez maximum 5 secondes
wade débat